so Chuck I'm going to tell you how to
boil water uh so for this explainer I am
going to go and get a
[Music]
sandwich you fill a pot with water now
you put it on the stove then you turn on
the heat be it electric coil or gas this
is ground breaking
stuff so you're heating the pan right
and then the bottom of the pot is
heating the bottom of the water that
sense so far so you'd expect the water
at the bottom of the pot to be hotter
than the water at the top of the pot
yeah as it gets hot the water molecules
vibrate faster and faster and if your
molecule sitting next to me m and you're
not vibrating as fast as I am I'm like
calm down man calm down what is your
problem jeez but you will ultimately
succumb and my vibrations will send you
into vibrating you will send the
adjacent molecules next to you you it's
called conduction it's how if you have a
fireplace poker or the handle of an iron
pan on the stove the pan gets hot
eventually the handle gets cot Lord have
I learned that the hard way okay so the
iron molecules start vibrating and they
they tickle the molecules next to it set
them vibrating that is heat energy going
out of the pan up the handle to your
hand to burn you unless you get a PO
holder right so the liquid will con
conduct
heat until that's not fast enough
conducting is slow you could hold the
handle of an iron pan for at least 5
minutes long time meanwhile you're
frying an egg right yeah exactly so
there's a point where the heat is
vibrating the molecules faster than the
molecules can communicate that fact to
molecules above it aha so the solution
to
this is blob of
water Rise Up from the
bottom you don't see the early bits of
this okay because the water is
completely transparent and there aren't
any bubbles yet right but the hot water
rises right physically moves that can't
happen in your iron pan because it's
solid the iron can only move heat
through conduction right but the moment
the heat becomes s significant
whole pockets of water will rise up
replaced with cool pockets of water that
were above that come in below if I Rise
Up something's got to take its place
right if you want to test this next time
put in a few raisins at the bottom
sounds like an awful
dish so you'll see the raisin Bob up and
down inside the liquid oo and it's doing
that because it's following it's
following the pockets of water there you
go so convection is a way to get heat
from one place to to the other by
physically moving Blobs of the
stuff and so convection can happen in
solids but it can happen in liquids and
in air air gas okay but it's not boiling
yet what happens when it boils I'll tell
you when it's boiling it's boiling when
at the bottom of the
stove it is so hot the water at the base
of the pot turns into steam wait inside
inside wow so you have a a ball of steam
there and so plus it's gas gas
underwater is going to rise fast exactly
now the early bubbles of steam these are
cool the early bubbles you'll see them
start and as they move their way up they
get smaller and smaller and they
disappear right because the the water
above that layer is not at boiling
temperature yet it's cool it's cooler so
it's cooling down this steam bubble
turning it back into water interesting
so so when the bubble is formed and
keeps the same size the entire root to
the top then you have 212° boiling water
so boiling water is really just it's
just water farting basically that's
exactly what I was thinking
Chu if you fart in a swimming pool that
bubble will not disappear that'll just
stay a bubble all the way up that's the
easiest way to get kicked out of a party
why are there bubbles coming from your
suit coming from your rear end no none
of what I just said is why I have this
explainer with you okay plot twist have
you
ever had a pure pot of
water boil over oh no it never boils
over but
wait when you make spaghetti it can boil
over yes it can what is the most boil
over substance known to
man in a morning stove the most oh
oatmeal oatmeal oatmeal oatmeal oatmeal
so why does water not boil over but
oatmeal does why I will tell you I'm
ready there they are slowly coming up to
temperature the pure water gets to 22 a
blob of steam Rises up and escapes the
top right what happen that same blob of
steam in the oatmeal it can't get out
right there's oatmeal in the way but it
has to get out right thermodynamically
it has to escape so you have these
Bubbles and say we're getting out no
matter what we're busting loose out of
this pot and the only way to do that is
to
expand the layers of oatmeal so that it
has pockets of water that it can come
out through if you start out with a pot
of oatmeal that's 1/3 full that puppy
will expand to the complete height of
the pan so that the steam can get out
the sun when it
dies you always heard it say it becomes
a red giant right when the Sun dies it
runs out of hydrogen in its core
converted all the hydrogen to helium all
right there's a certain Luminosity
associated with that fine now I just
have helium what's next
the sun collapses then it starts fusing
helium into
carbon that happens at a higher
Luminosity the sun gets brighter more
energy is coming in from the core of the
Sun but wait that energy can't get out
of the previous Sun it has the same
problem with the
oatmeal okay the previous Sun had a had
a transparency of energy to it that gave
it its current size right when you boost
the energy level of the core it can't
get out until it busts out and it is
going to get out and on Route it takes
the Sun and swells it oh into the size
of a red giant star now the energy can
get out and it goes from its current
size to hundreds of times bigger oh my
goodness you thought your oatmeal
spilled over the sun is basically
spilling over out of its pot wow which
is why if you want to tame the oatmeal
you have to lower the heat lower the
heat as much as you can we can't do that
to the sun the sun is stuck with the
high energy it's going to puff up and
become a huge Red Giant star so under
high heat the oatmeal wants to become a
big giant star basically trying to get
the energy out right right lower the
heat which the sun doesn't have the
power to do now it can bubble and you
can cook the oion so the sun has no
choice but to go ahead to keep expanding
correct until it becomes its own
delicious breakfast
explosion whereas you the chef in the
morning have the option to lower the
heat on the oatmeal right so the oatmeal
boils over for the same reason the sun
gets big the energy can't get out and it
has to thin things up above it so that
the energy can find its way out and it
does that's super cool that's how to
boil
water the grass Tyson
here keep looking up
[Music]
a